DLo in these last 3 weeks is trade
rumors tend to intensify um you've
played some of the best basketball of
your season um how have you been able to
to do that and then what will the next
48 hours be in terms of do you get away
from stuff even more so and the build of
the deadline how do you kind of handle
it I don't care at
all show up to
work that's it um kind of piggy back in
on that not just to ask the same
question a different way but maybe this
is a more interesting question
uh you know the last six weeks since the
tailbone injury you played really well
uh you can't control you can control
what you do playing right so does that
give you any sort of peace of mind um as
you move forward I mean I can't control
that my contract makes sense to be
traded either so I mean just play can't
control that um once again I don't care
at all just cuz you brought it up um
what happened this summer like how did
it become to be that your contract was
able to be traded cuz you would have had
a tacit no trade agreement in your deal
uh I just thought it made sense um
obviously I've been here before I played
for the Lakers before so I know what the
requirements are to be um successful
here are so um if you're part of the
future here you'll be successful if
you're not you'll get traded and I've
been traded before here so my Approach
is just a little different um I really
just genuinely humbly don't care because
I know I can't control it one and two I
just won't allow my mind to go there um
I like to focus on this and you guys see
I've been focusing on basketball and not
comments and what's trending on social
so